would you would you date
would you would you see a woman has less
value if
for example if they have a like a
history of maybe dating the wrong man
yeah because i think i think women
struggle with this so much because as a
man obviously you can you can confirm to
me as well when you're young and you're
like 16
you got no money
you got no chest
you've just you're just you've not
barely hit puberty and the 19 year old
swirls up in his little ford focus and
grabs your babes and you're told like
bro bro when you get a bit older you can
have a girl like this but for now you
have to deal with what you have to do
you have to build yourself up
boys don't get upset with it like you
know israel is the older drug dealer he
had more money to miguel is what is but
when you say to a woman
that in reverse
that your value is decreasing
it's almost like they can't fathom it
like it's an exception to the rule and
this thing over
it's not that hard to grasp that
when you get older you're just going to
get less attention to think that in your
40s you can get the same caliber of man
that you could at 23.
it's not really that hard to grasp it's
like we tried to use nicer words to to
say it to say i think they see it as
like
attack on the value of them yeah it's
not attacking the value of damage you
remember the sexual marketplace the
dating marketplace is like any capital
markets any form of capitalism the best
product marketed in the best way always
gets the best outcome so the best
product in this case
would be your body marking it might be
what you wear social media the filters
you use and that's what you're going to
go into attract the most interest when
you're in your 40s 50s no matter how
much you market a dead product
when the breast ain't breasted and it's
sagging and you can do keep your peas
with the breast like
it's not the same product i'm sorry and
we have to remember i'm sorry
men and women are different many women
are different they look at things
different we go through life different
everything is different the way you go
through life is completely different the
way i go through life you understand so
it's like
men will look at your path
to see if you qualify for my future
women are looking at a man's future
do you understand like you want to know
that yeah this guy can provide for any
future offerings of offspring that we
might have this guy can provide for me
he can give me security that's all
future based a man will look at your
past do you understand like who have you
who have you dared like was your hoe
like you know have you been run through
jonathan these are all past stuff james
and just to see if you qualify for his
future and if you if you obviously in
your past you know you did things in
your past that makes you disqualified
then that's just how the cookie crumbles
because it's got remember if you've
worked all this time to attain this and
you've made all the best choices that's
why you see a lot of older man in terms
of forget beauty from the side
a lot of older men will wife younger
women i'm not saying [ __ ] stupid ages
i'm saying like 30 to 23. just for the
reason of
less
less chance of baggage she's like why
would i grab a 30 year old that if maybe
she's still she's still single she's
been had all these
all these boyfriends that have affected
her she might have a kid when i can just
grab someone who's 23 and not have to
deal with that that's not to say he
might not meet someone who's hurt who
hasn't gone through all their things and
could be amazing but it's just a way of
chances
just like why go with the stress and
headache there's like a lot of women
when they
they might have an ex-road man who's now
going straight or they can go for the
investment bankers it's like you know
what this guy doesn't have a history of
violence why am i going to bother with
jerome the road man who's now [ __ ]
some forex guy that sells stuff on
instagram when i can just get a solid
investment banker he's just
revised his whole life it's just a way
of odds it just makes sense
do you think that investment banker
wouldn't choose then that obviously her
full date in there uh well that kind of
goes back to the start question of
should well i was talking about assess
it in two parts should he date her and
will she
still find him
attractive because 10 years ago she
thought the bad boys were attractive so
first of all in terms of the attraction
it all comes back to what i'm saying
about alphanus
alfonus is a situation and that's what
makes you alpha so a lot of people say
man will say i'm an alpha but you're not
your alpha in the situation you're
putting so to give you an example
and this is a bit of a [ __ ] example
that roller tomassie uses is that a lot
of
you see that that trend of when a
teacher
will
like
leave his wife for like a young 18 year
old woman
and he was his teacher and they say he
groomed at which he did that's he did he
did gruma but in that situation the
reason why he managed to unlock her is
because he controls the classroom
everyone looks up to him
he's the teacher he might be a dweeb in
life but he's the alpha in that
classroom and that's the way she's got
to know him so that's how he's unlocked
her brain
now you when you see eventually when she
awakens is when she leaves the classroom
is run off with him and realize he's
just dweeb and no one respects him he
hasn't got money and no one values him
you see what the difference between
going on going with mr roadman or for
the americans for mr hood guy
he's a bad man then and everyone
respects him in the hood at that age but
then when you get to your 30s it's the
guys with the money it's the highest
value status guy no matter how old you
get
those values don't diminish from a 30
year old for 30 years old if you're a
millionaire you're a boss for life
you're bossing the old person's um
you're smoking all the old ladies i'm
saying you're just a boss anywhere so
that's why i think it's a thing of the
attraction will still stay there it's
not a problem but whether you want to
then go deal with a woman that's got the
baggage of a bad guy is a different
thing yeah well and guys know like who
they were in high school so like if a
guy was a dweeb in high school and now
he's worked for 10 years to get to a
certain status and then this girl says i
used to date bad boys all the time
or like i had this toxic x or this this
guy did this or this guy that says
taking no accountability always painting
herself as the victim like one men can
see through [ __ ] because it takes
two to tango and two they also
realized that you would have passed on
them
like if they yeah go ahead yeah like i i
i i agree with what you're saying like
it in terms of you know if a woman does
go in like and
is toxic and has that toxic situation
she could definitely carry that through
to her next relationship but
then it's like
that healing has to take place and that
person's got to find peace with their
past and i still think that
you can find peace but like the world is
harsh and the dating pla like the dating
marketplace is harsh so just because
you've personally found peace and moved
on from that doesn't mean that the
world's going to give you understanding
so i think maybe
let's say for example you know how we
said like for a woman for a man to kind
of accept a woman she has to kind of
tick eighty percent of these boxes
whereas for women it's a hundred percent
right remember that that was that was
yeah yeah yeah well it we yeah okay
close yeah yeah just keep going yeah
so it's like okay so if a if a woman is
able to show that who she is as a person
is
meets that standard of the guy then
maybe that the baggage part of it well
yeah but like we we deal in
probabilities not possibilities so like
that's that's again
illustrating my point a little bit when
i say like women are children because
even now you're thinking of like the
possibilities not the probabilities and
it comes to how the male and female mind
is is different a lot of men
falling women fall in love with what
like you could be that's why you see a
lot of women will try to fix a guy
whereas a man will
fall in love with the idea that she
won't change so he meet the 23 year old
buddy and he doesn't want her to change
and he'll just based it on all of her
past experiences to the point i've met
her now
she's had this kind of pass she's 23
she's sexy and this is how it's going to
be whereas women will fall in love with
the future so that's why the way you're
talking is like ah but they can be they
can be they can be that's not how men
think they just think i've looked at
this
that's what it is mateys all the
materials from the football team have
run through this is long i can't be
bothered and what if she like i was just
out of curiosity like what if she didn't
tell you and
it was like and you you got and you
fell in love with her let's say to speak
and you find out
she dated like bad men back in the day
all right depending on the guy
depending on the guy like you know
personally i've the guys that i know
don't leave
yeah yeah even if he was in love because
love is a choice you have to remember
that love is a choice you choose who you
love do you understand because you're
looking that from a female point of view
because from a female it's like if we
fall in love like well i'll overlook the
10 red flags but from a male point of
view they're like
costs benefit
in a man's eyes anyway love is a choice
i chose to love you do you understand
because you showed me that you showed me
you know
you showed me things that i felt like
was valuable
so i'm choosing to love you i'm choosing
to speak into the mind i'm choosing to
give you um
these my my resource basically you
understand if i now found out that you
know you was on oni fans or you you've
been ran through
like you know you've basically deceived
me so you're so you're going to ever so
let's just put it into one example right
so you're going to disregard
everything that she is as a as a person
that you're feeling in that moment that
experience that you've had with her and
then you'll just be like oh yeah well
because now i know that you've had a
past
that changes my current experience
that's like okay that's like selling a
car for new prices and then later he
found out the car has a bunch of issues
and he he brings it back to the shop
yeah that's the equivalent it's like
again this is what men value
they they value youth they value purity
and they value they value loyalty
and being hot i'll give you an example
um i was talking to one girl one time
and this was like years ago
and
we she checked everything like we we had
it all good it was going well um and one
of my boys came up to me and said yo
like if she
i heard one of the guys in his
friendship group
had said that she had been unfaithful
and at that moment i just went no
i'm out you just feel disgusted
it was it was literally like that it
wasn't even a case where i wanted to
know
i had a conversation with her but i
didn't even tell her
what actually happened
and i said look i don't think this is
going to work out
um
how long was you dating her for us say
three four months
but it's put pearl in in the uk we call
it crb or dbs checks
i don't know what you call them in the
us but it's basically like it's like a
it's like a play on words or what you do
a criminal background check
so you just say to the man them like ah
put the feeler out i like this girl like
what do you know about it she's from
here ask the man from over there
and then sometimes you get bad reports
here just like
could have been so much
it could have been so much man but there
are sometimes cases where
guys don't want you to leave the pack
and they will they will say stuff about
the girl
yeah i mean
but that's why you have to and that's
why what you have to say to them and
like you have to say like what's the
intel source because some guys will say
ah she's a slag because she slept with
two guys but that might just be two guys
from the same area they're from like
what you expect i think when you come
with age as well it's almost like when
someone says like oh she's been run
through that all right she's had a
one-night stand like come on bro like
grow up like [ __ ] happens in it it's
more like we do talk a run-through
uh he went to that matey and then she
was in a room and then she was getting
bakaki then it was like [ __ ] you know